wenn ich an sozial nein ich habe ihn
vergiftet
innerlich schnell ich hab nix
die kammer nicht gut an hallo ich meine
lieben freund und herzlich willkommen zu
einer weiteren folge minecraft die hexen
ich wollte ein megaprojekt youtube am
projekt zusammen mit l p midcap die
dritte folge am stück ich connect auf
dem server und allerlei leben meiner
seite aus und ich muss sagen ich bin
sehr froh mal wieder mit menschlichen
wesen aufzunehmen weil ich ja die
letzten folgen wirklich sehr also nicht
die letzten beiden mit ziemer
ausgenommen aber davor war ich ja sehr
alleine
also ich weiß nicht warum das bei mir
immer noch nicht games ich kann ich das
ja auch irgendwie also das ist bei mir
wenn ich was nochmal connect denn
einfach zu wenig kontakte obwohl ich
weiß nicht wie ich kontakte vans topstar
angeht
früher musste ich sogar neu starten
die pfeile sind immer noch da ich musste
irgendwie ausstellen können oder control
list player arm um meine es gibt nur mit
f7 irgendwie ich nehme mit 11 7 auf er
dann mach ich habe das auch schon
umgestellt das dorf komplett umstellen
aber so auch in räume aufnahm playoffs
schneidet sich mit nicht dann mache ich
wieder mal ganz kurz ein kind geboren
habe ich wieder am start das müsste
glaube ich klappen etwa die sachen aber
mit 11 7 ich kann's auch schon jetzt
läuft alles sehr dankbar
ich liebe dich auch und kämpft was soll
uns sagen was sollte ein buch von dir
ach so ja klar kannst dich einfach
abholen weißt du wo ich wohne ich möchte
mich erst mal wieder sagen ja beim
friedhof ich möchte ich auch
doch nicht die möchte ich erst mal
wieder sehen hier alle
ich habe ein geschenk würde ich gönn dir
gehört zu clou alter würde
das hat ja auch meine frau hat das glas
protect was heißt das das ist das
protection explosionsschutz ich habe
viel schutz bei mir doch es war auch gut
dass ein walkers wort ich möchte gern
hier mit schlagen hatte die fenster
genau so fort und trete ich bin mit der
sense etwas töten weil dann
kristallpunkte glaube ich goal.com was
mit dem kaufen ich weiß ich weiß nicht
nur kartoffeln ist dann komme ich gleich
dazu
mit zu dir bitte etwas wie jungen wir
wollen ihn natürlich alle wieder an das
ist natürlich wir sind natürlich die
sozialen menschen hier in den stab drin
na klar es war es dann warten lassen
klar wie also kommt ich hab auch noch
sachen für dich so komme ich zwar dachte
ich dass ich hier so 1 hier ja ich habe
für den arm
nachdem hier das ja das sind diese mal
machen also dass da hab ich für dich das
hab ich für dich impress dahinter
ach so dass das ist einmal ein sattel
und glühwein platz im inventar hier und
jetzt auch noch bücher haben wie viele
bücher brauchst du eigentlich für die
verzauberung tisch wie viele denn weil
das war das was soll das rechtsmittel
wolle kriegst du von mir leuchtet ach so
das heißt bücher und ich habe nämlich
ein yellow sac spider dance party machen
jetzt will ich den job osbourne einfach
mal hier
mit giacomo sattel erstmal bosco saal
das war nicht etwa etwas wohl nicht
wegläuft ja aber der läuft nicht weg
diese die laufen nicht weg diese nicht
ganz da sponnen einfach erstmal jetzt
macht jetzt machen sattel drauf und
yamaha komm wir machen ein chocobo er
versuchte vergeblich
das ist schon okay die nase rein wie
willst du deinen denkt wie wie kann ich
ihnen also noch nicht ich habe den
bisher einfach nur seinen namen gegeben
aber ich mache das gleich noch mit einem
tape eigentlich mit magic büro weiß
nicht aber das ein komisches fonds jetzt
so thomas diewald heiden zieht wenn man
so blöcke schläger der macht irgendwas
spezielles also ich hab irgendwann mit
butter beste tun
ich verbringe so etwas stärker walker
spot oder das andere ich mit gästen aber
muss ja irgendwo ein schwarzes rom 13
läufer 14 ins haus rein tokio wo kinder
ins haus
hallo gar nicht ein laufen die
eigentlich weg jakobus ja wenn ich
brauche diese bleiben stehen die bleiben
stehen du kannst ja so absetzen sollte
was ich noch zeigen wollte und zwar ich
in pakistan mal eine ganze tasche aus
und ein wie auch immer mit 2x auch
diverse gold blöcke diamond blöcke
pipapo alles vom allerfeinsten schick
kannst du ganz gut schlafen gehen ja gar
nicht kochen dann zeige ich dir einfach
mal die beiden hoch weil ich weiß
wirklich nicht wo der unterschied ist
also ich muss wirklich meine hunde
wiederfinden
das kann ich so ein bisschen traurig
dass meine hunde einfach weg sind ich
habe den so schön schon namen gegeben
achso und wien am tag geht wollte ich
machen damit alle meine tiere sondern
haben du kannst doch eingeben und der
könig das ist ja aber nicht dazu
gekommen
ja stimmt auch mano so kommst dann die
hauptstraße dann ja ich komme auch manu
ich möchte gerne den namen geben
würdest du spinnst du deine fenster
alter was ist das ich hab dich du kannst
wenig ziehen oder was auch immer zu
ziehen
du kannst dich ziehen immer klar dass
ich weiter hochklassig heraus als auch
nichts gegen malawi ziel jetzt einfach
ja ich will aber im block drin
kannst ja ich weiss und die andere hoch
ist halt dass hier quartet das
wahrscheinlich zu weit weg wie du kannst
mir das einmal geben ich möchte das auch
einmal machen dass wir zwei
verschiedenen dass hier einmal die das
ist die richtig selten also die spieler
hoch das sei dann relativ carlo hat
einfach so rum ziehen was eigentlich
find ich find es auch automatisch was
ich bin darauf gespannt ist siehst du
mich halt einfach nur schneller versuche
da kommt ja wie schnell ich bin dagegen
zu laufen
okay lass uns in zwei verschiedene
richtungen laufen zu sein
für big boss geil ist das denn alter
aber wenn ich doch jetzt hier mit
schaden bekommen boxe ich habe ganz kurz
einfach nur ohne irgendwie eine waffe
oder so einfach durchsetzen boxen mit
dem ich kann mit dem hotspot recht
machen damit ich mich wieder auf nase
oder genauer schlag der mittel nicht mit
dem beiden sport allerdings nicht
verzaubert ja aber ich hab ein bisschen
anderen spot okay
die box einfach nur sexy schaden
du hast ein halbes herz schaden bekommt
ja okay ein herz ja was soll ich noch
dass das heil mich so nein das ist du
kriegst beim block sieht auf jeden fall
nur ein halbes jahr zu schaden egal
wichtig damit warum kommt so ich wollte
mir ging es auch noch eine backpack
machen eine bag hat ihn gefunden nämlich
erstmal sein kann ich denn das wäre es
wenn du das ziehen könnte hatte was wäre
so frech was lukas sich aber eine back
und in die bäcker sie ihr wissen aus dem
start aus dem fenster einfach nur glück
das ding ist kann mit dem hochziehen mit
dem spyder sword wii und das hat ihn
endlich haltbarkeit
ja das führt schon gezeigt ja war das
klingt ich wusste ich dass ich den hut
ziehen kann
das heißt dass spidey kann sich ziehen
und ist genug sagt die karnickel
schenken das ist bislang nur hochziehen
kann kein spieler ziehen
der pott zum geil danke 60 zum aus
megageil alter geschenke geschenke
geschenke da merkt man das irgendwie
eine stattfinden
ja das ist irgendwie so das geile kannst
du den gesammelten allerletzten
megaprojekte man dann immer guten für
die großzügige spende punkt ja hier ist
mehr soll es in deiner stadt wir helfen
uns immer gegenseitig der eine braucht
ein buch im buch genau war schon
vergessen ja versorgung für chicago
37 ich habe mich zum schoko bohr
angezogen aber wir sind für immer
verbunden auch wenn ich weg lauf ich
kann nicht weg
hast du was machst du eigentlich eine
rüstung was brauchst irgendwas an
rüstung ich habe nur ein renault rüstet
euch vielleicht jemand oder mir wurde
gesagt ich kann das sexy kalex tänzen
eine machen aber ich habe mexiko
diamonds auf keinen fall benutzen erst
mal warum nicht weil die ist die
wertvollste bewährung dirigiere ich ja
deswegen weil ich mehr daraus machen
wirklich wertvollen alter meinst du ja
weiß ich würde mir schon gesagt hat mein
electric stuff der ist übel zum 8 sie
verstehe nicht was daraus friert jetzt
70 barry teilen könnt ihr nochmal
schreiben die kartoffel kann ich auch
braten ich wollte noch einen ofen etwa
ohne wird euch etwas zeigen
ich habe gerade ohne was das mainzer
cobo job goldene feder ja machen alle
musst du jacobo töten um die feder zu
bekommen habe ich wollte nicht dass da
ein tötet deswegen haben
und zwar habe ich gerade verzauberten
chassan ohne bücherregale und ohne ein
level das kann man doch verzaubern
warte mal ganz zu behalten fällt ein
bisschen jetzt alles kaputt
ja kaputt und hatte richtig glück dass
hamburg gefallen ist wissen nicht wann
wir jetzt neu ist weil ich gerade noch
nicht gekommen
ja mussten irgendwann mal beibringen
bezaubern ich muss mir jetzt ein
bisschen cobblestone holen damit ich mir
machen kann und mein haus befindet diese
kathedrale ist hier fast halb
eingerissen und so dass das nicht wieder
teile gemacht wurde und ich weiß nicht
um findest du das schön wenn überall
gras ist ich finde es cool wenn wir uns
so einen eigenen wald anlegen würden
vielleicht weil ich hab grad um den
friedhof auch abgebaut weil ich das auch
mal hässlich fand
lasst uns doch einfach lass uns doch mal
allerdings bauen so ein bisschen wald
mäßig so ein paar geile bäume weg nach
sotschi sind solche was geiles zeigen
auch wenn kein playboy ist auch ein bug
von hexe premiere kommentare geschrieben
und zwar ich habe hier einen bestimmten
stattgefunden
wir dürfen aber keine banken betreiben
es ist kein bug using also alles nur so
weil es ja nicht unmittelbar
wo bist du denn ich bin immer wenn ich
an sozial nein ich habe vor hier
vergiftet verinnerlicht
ich hab nix wird die kammer nicht getan
hab ihn gefragt habe ihn geheilt
ja ich habe geheult weil ich jetzt auf
ihm drauf ich glaub ich helfe ihm vorbei
man sieht auch die zeit und ich hab mir
grad folge halt etwas dauern weil das
ist dieser posten stattgefunden aber
auch mit anna allem heftes fast jeden
tag alles aus sich machen einmal rechts
ich und du bist vergiftete 30 sekunden
war scheiße eltern das ist ließ
gegenspieler ist es nicht so heftig war
ex alter selber vorher gestorben junge
der alkohol ja nicht so mit gefühle mit
denen er diesen so niedlich schoki
bleibt über da aber ich möchte meine
hunde wieder sonst muss ich mir neue
hundefamilie das wäre so kacke wenn
jetzt alle weg werden
ich hoffe einfach noch mal zurück und
sucht die es ist einfach so ein
arschloch
aber das gute ist jetzt im versorgungs
tisch kann ich wenigstens diamanten
verkauf alter scheiß aufweisen dass
nichts mehr wert ist
ich habe auch ich habe auch ein stück
eisen aber auch einstige jammern ich
weiß nicht was ich damit machen mehr
diamanten als alles ist der feinste
schick von allem da kommen
ich sollte jetzt mal wieder ein bisschen
ich glaube ich werde mein haus auf das
aus bird sachen machen damit das einfach
ein bisschen heller ist abschnittsleiter
fischen sieht man was für was was wie
wann breaking
wer noch gar keine bäume umgebung ein
bisschen so hornets damit an breaking
abfischen ziehen und bäume ich brauche
dich brauche sharp touch was eichendorf
libyen brauche ich also ich hab jetzt an
breaking 2 und fischen sie zwei ohne ein
vertrauter einem bücherregal in geklickt
sport bei dir wichtig dermaßen heftig
alter an breaking wave ii gruppe dr
wenig ist natürlich ist diese blume hier
sexy carl ist ja ich hab noch eine
existenz gefunden um da hat der
geschwindigkeit mit der man leben aber
eher leute sollte ich mir mit hexal
essenzen soll ich mir daraus am besten
gegen eine rüstung machen oder soll ich
mir daraus irgendwas anderes machen was
würdet ihr sagen wir daraus machen kann
schon mal die kommentare hier sind fixe
ja dass ihn das war die erfangen
wie kann ich diese akkus einfach nur
einverleiben
mit fleisch wahrscheinlich habe ich also
gebratenes fleisch wolken sind dann
sollten sie nicht
vielleicht in das vegetarische fuchs und
die wollen karotten kleine kammer zu
machen
ich habe sogar eine puppe fehler wurden
die goldene feder dass noch zwei andere
federn
keine ahnung vielleicht habe ich die
auch alte dies noch besser als weil die
linke ist nicht verzauberte sie denn
fast versteht ja mit einer goldenen
feder bekommst du keinen fall schaden
mehr glaube ich wenn ich im moment aber
ist ja möglich
ja ich glaube schon wenn ich direkt
klicken einfach sitzen
ich mache jetzt nochmal 25 ich glaube
man kann sich auch
schuhe machen womit du gar keinen fall
schaden mehr bekommst und zwar auch aus
der goldenen feder ich würde jetzt gerne
in die kommentare gucken mir geschrieben
wurden
ja aber dafür muss ich einfach mal
minecraft wieder minimieren gläubig und
dann wird die aufnahme wieder so komisch
warum lecken
ich kann es mir gleich ganz kurz machen
wenn ich wieder zu hause bin das wäre in
einer minute glaube ich dass kann ich
was sage ich einfach so dermaßen schnell
also allem man darf immer nur so eine
folge aufnehmen weil man möchte auch
nicht zu weit forciert haben
verständlich denke ich dass hier kann
auch weg was tasten künftig komme gleich
nochmal wieder hin
so traf dem jetzt ebenso ein dings altar
alter kraft ist eben ein
allerdings hat zack
egal was
also muss sagen dieses fliegen ist schon
echt chillig beim bauen muss man einfach
so sagen wie fliegende roboter bis jetzt
endlich hat praktisch gedacht oh wir
müssen schlafen gehen
ich bin doch jetzt folgen sowieso in
einer minute vorliegen werden wir
statten gehen zeit nur vier minuten
wieder immer so blöd mit dem fehler aber
der fehler kommt jetzt nicht mehr vor ja
das ja schon mal ganz gut läuft so und
dann natürlich ein theoretisch gucken
wie ich mir diese schule mache mit denen
ich keinen fall schaden wir bekommen wir
dass wir auf jeden fall mal ganz schnell
voll da bist im dungeon springt einfach
raus und kriegst du keinen fall schaden
ist auch das schöne mit diesem
zauberstab war da kriegst du soweit ich
weiss auch keinen fall schaden wenn du
zuvor hoch geflogen ist mit freund jörn
mothes team bald raus raus
nichts da
also ich muss an dieser stelle wieder
sagen und dass die folge vorbei ist und
ich bedanke mich bei luca war schaut
natürlich auch bei ihm vorbei zu sein
gesicht wie ein bisschen verschiedene
sachen auf haben uns da zwischendurch
getroffen aber ich denke da ist doch das
ein oder andere interessante dabei und
dann würde ich einfach sagen sehen wir
uns in der nächste folgen in der in der
nächsten folge wenn ich wieder heißt
minecraft ganz klein bisschen weiter und
zwar habe ich ja noch ein bisschen zeit
hier
deswegen habe ich mir gedacht ich kann
hier schon ein bisschen hier investiert
ein paar wochen mit hier was ist das
hier gar nichts das in paris gleich auf
dem rennen kommt zwei sticks müssen wir
da schon ein bischen zu essen ist auf
jeden fall geil muss man auf jeden fall
haben
jetzt würde ich gleich nach hause laufen
und dann wahrscheinlich kurz schlafen
gehen wenn der kamera oder noch schlafen
geht
ich denke ich dass hier gibt wieder
schlafen gehen glaubt da geht nicht
schlafen daheim bestimmt nicht leiden
wie kunden denkt ich bin also sagen ich
finde eigentlich ne geile jetzt man die
zeit haben wir überlegt ich wollte mir
so ein luftschloss bauen aus haus und
jetzt passt und manchmal schöne wachen
ständer wo ich alle meinen ganzes
gesammeltes die clips so wie die mit
propson guck mal hier der glänzende und
oben also luftschloss milliarden wohnte
könig dem haus ab oder könig am ersten
elf kommt die folge bei vermutlich allen
von uns zur königswall dort wird der
könig gewählt der stadt ein monats
anlaufzeit
ich weiß noch nicht genau ob ich das
hochladen kann
aber ich denke das ist auch urlaub ja
wenn ich muss man sich auch irgendwie
informiert
ich habe jetzt noch drei minuten
deswegen ich hätte es hier noch ganz
kurz sortieren nächstes mal werde ich
dann weiterbauen auf jeden fall in
meinem heußlein also ich hab ich hier
rein die ganzen wertvollen sachen das
ist eine show coupe du das hier sind
auch ich habe mit schoko federn ich habe
noch keine goldene feder aus dem kokon
rausbekommt grabmale single player was
man denn aus dieser goldenen chaco
fehler machen kann das ganz interessant
oder können daran ja das darf mir
interessant so ich nehme es hermann nur
bären mit am besten so ein bisschen wie
viele goldene aktien und zum goldenen
fehler ich schieb motto wir sind weder
verlassen menschen
man kann überhaupt nichts doch keiner
aus einer normalen fehler und acht gold
lücken aber eine goldene firma ist
ziemlich wertvoll schätze ich macht man
kann sich genau einmal nur vier goldene
feder da machst du die cloud heraus
vier goldene federn ja und du kannst ja
auch eine goldene feder aus einer
normalen feder und acht goldbarren
kräften acht gold werden der kompost
okay ich habe ich hab neuen gold das
habe ich alles ohne gaddafi
schau mal was eine laterne bringt dann
kann man sich vielleicht doch
orientieren
eine laterne ja man kann ich erst einmal
nur hinstellen ist damit durch eine
höhle dann beleuchtet die alles weißt du
ja ich weiß dass mir egal gewesen
bei mir ist so heftig am reden das ist
krass ich weiß eigentlich dass das gold
noch eben schnell fertig wird damit ich
mir noch ebenso eine goldene feder
machen kann locker vier stück davon
ja es braucht 24 goldbank hast du dir da
aber ich habe jetzt vier goldbarren
schon deswegen das mache jetzt noch eben
dass ich mir eine goldene feder macht
war ich glaube auch eine goldene feder
bewirkt schon dass man keinen fall
schaden mehr bekommen die mussten man
dann halt im inventar haben dann kann
man sich aus vier goldenen feder anhalt
das ding machen und ich kann mir noch
einen tipp geben wenn wir auch in die
kommentare geschrieben wurde dann hilft
ihr wahrscheinlich auch und zwar gibt es
einen metalldetektor und ein meteor roxy
detektor wiederum heißt alles gibt auch
und meteor crash detektor es gibt
nämlich so ruhig dass ich dann sehe wo
er mit jungen absichtlich und zwar werde
ich nicht von sternschnuppen weil dies
kriegen nur wirklich sondern stern teil
kann ich rede von wichtigen meteoren
wurden auch so außerirdische erz und
sodann dran ist will ich was ist
eigentlich schon ganz okay ich habe
jetzt eine goldene feder ich habe jetzt
einfach in meinem inventar drin
ich werde das jetzt noch ganz kurz
probieren ob ich dann damit irgendwo
wenn ich dann irgendwo dräger vom
hochhaus ja ich will es mal probieren
dass ich irgendwo auf wir und dann
einfach mal runterkommen aber nicht so
nicht so lehne hauptsache die ganze tour
ist freiwillig hier einfach alles ist
zerbombt und ich ja immer noch immer
durch die tür okay ich von hier oben
runter will ich keinen fall schaden mehr
auch wenn man schon eine goldene feder
von inventar hat okay leute dann will
ich sagen dass wartet auch von mir bei
mir das hier nämlich mein letztes mal im
haus und habe ich sagen es euch gefallen
hat den daumen hoch gegeben bei cap
könnt ihr auch vorbeigucken der
deutschen jeden fall auch spannende
sachen gemacht mein job und ich sind
jetzt endlich wieder in der stadt
angekommen und mein haus nimmt langsam
formen an
es wird auf jeden fall haben wir im
nächsten jahr eine zunächst mal und to
georgia